my name is Julia Louis-Dreyfus hi
and I feel
you know not much okay about being
coated so it's like a it's a dead
feeling it's a really you just feel that
it's not dead I mean I feel very much
alive personally but
when I come here it's a different yeah I
noticed you were kind of full of life I
saw you getting out of your car and you
just seemed very animated yeah a real uh
hop in my step yeah and then as you
greeted me I saw the light go out of
your eyes well I don't know what to tell
you man
I love it I love a just an incredible
honesty thank you so much for being here
well thank you for including me in your
fancy uh
situ oh are we being videotaped yeah oh
okay I should have gotten proper hair
and makeup you look amazing no I don't
yeah you do you do you do all right
there you go thank you
assuming but I should put lipstick on
I'd put lipstick on you want some of
mine I'm gonna give you my lipstick
please wear lipstick for this episode
put some lipstick but then my germs will
be on is it okay if I really use that I
don't care oh wow it's your color too
it's kind of a copper yeah okay
all right because you should know I
don't know anything about this
[Laughter]
idiot
because I haven't done it before Oh no
you look like a drunk clown oh God how
does it look so good on her it's so
awesome first of all I have to say the
color's not bad on him right yeah this
would be my color what color is this
well it's it's made by MAC cosmetics and
it's faux okay well we know
we know what my color is is faux and I'm
committing to this good and now at some
point I might wipe it off if we start
talking about something really heavy
I don't know I might wipe it off this is
so much of it the only issue really
honestly it does look good is that it's
out yeah it's out of bounds which is uh
which is does have sort of an insane
asylum look to it do you know what I
mean real Joker thing going on but isn't
that the classic thing when a uh can I
fix your lips yes okay does this up
the podcast no not at all this is
dynamic it enhances yeah oh I had the
stream once okay quiet okay quiet
hmm yeah wow that's good this is
special does anybody have makeup remover
this man has done a number
look at me
yeah it's better okay now mascara okay
now listen we'll leave your fantasies
out of this man damn hose pantyhose
um someone will tell you that I am a
Serial over applier oh my God like when
I put sunblock on or anything on this is
angry like it's an angry kind of Irish
coffee yeah but that's good about
sunscreen yeah but when I brush my teeth
I brush them real hard and my gums bleed
and I've had dentists say your your
skull is coming apart yeah because of
the way you brush your teeth okay and
I'll say uh I just hate myself and they
go yeah you're just gonna you gotta try
and just chill when you brush your teeth
um but listen back to me and then and
then back to you again and then back to
me a third time
and then getting to me uh wow I think
yeah we're running out of time we're
doing pretty much done you were right to
uh really not feel anything when you
came in here you were right your
instincts were were on target this is
your second appearance on the podcast
okay
[Laughter]
yeah and uh so clearly you were
delighted or your team was delighted so
they had you uh come back yes your
wishes yes
um
and uh I just love having you here you
are adored you know that people that's
very nice of you to say I actually did
have a good time when I was on your
podcast last time it was one of the
first podcasts I'd ever done I think and
now you have a podcast oh yeah and now I
have a podcast you have a podcast now
and I listen to your interview with Jane
Fonda and I thought it was great you
have a terrific podcast voice I'm not a
fan of my voice but I think your voice
is really good thank you
it's a great idea for a podcast too
wiser than me wiser than me yeah which
is uh you're talking to older women
um getting their wisdom that's the plan
when I first heard you heard you had a
podcast and that you had done a bunch my
initial
thought was I was hurt that I wasn't
invited and then I heard that the
premise was I'm talking to older women
and then I thought again I still think I
could qualify
come on it's just you know the guy who's
right on the edge maybe uh but it's a
terrific idea it's really thank you yeah
it's it's been kind of mind expanding to
do it and uh and also daunting because
I'm talking to some hyper-intelligent
people and so but I got the idea because
I saw did you see Jane Fonda's um the
documentary about her yeah Jane Fonda in
five acts yeah and I was so blown away
by the scope of her life and and
everything that she's done and and
thought and and Ben
and then I started thinking well we we
need why are we not hearing from older
women right I mean for real why are we
not hearing from older women and so that
was really the Genesis of this and and
uh and it's been
just pretty mind-blowing that I've
talked to Isabel Allende and
Fran Leibowitz please so fabulous but
lots of but all walks of life and it's
been Darlene Love and uh I'm talking to
Carol Burnett tomorrow that's amazing
yeah I know she's
and some people people throw around
National Treasure and you think yeah
Carol Burnett she should be in there
sometimes they throw that term around
and you think no right not National
Treasure right
um but uh yes my God my God my God and
she's like gonna be 90. oh
yes isn't that remarkable yeah she's
gonna be 90 years old God love her great
yeah yeah what an extraordinary life she
said anyway so it's been interesting
just to go look to do it through the
lens of you know give me tips from the
front lines of life which is where you
are you know right and tell us
tell me what I should know what do you
wish you had known now that you know it
and um you know and it's been pretty
fantastic I also find it uh something
happened I think for most of human
history
we revered old people that's right they
were the elders yeah we made them the
keepers of all the wisdom and then
sometime around 1966 we decided that
anyone uh over 40 was an idiot and
shouldn't be listened to and I think
that was a mistake I'm sorry this is the
serious moment where you forget you're
wearing lipstick oh I don't forget it
I think especially women need to be
heard at this moment and this lipstick
is helping me
take it's gonna it's gonna come like
what if I start really talking about how
racism is a problem I really start
talking about very serious stuff or
genocide in some foreign country and the
video comes out of me with this makeup
on it looks like you've just had a
fudgesicle yeah I I gotta say I don't
think it's bad I think it's a it's a
subtle color so I'm not I I think it
works for you yeah it's gonna smoosh it
around a little it feels good too
yeah what's that here's a Kleenex what
does that do I don't know if you wanted
to take it off because you're trying to
make a serious point about aging
gracefully I actually think that um
that uh uh older women are particularly
discarded you know more so than men yes
no doubt yeah and uh uh so you know
let's change that narrative I listened
to one with uh Jane Fonda and it looked
like you'd put a lot of thought into it
and it felt very well
um constructed especially the the the
the first part and I thought huh that's
different than my Approach
we go in half-assed and start babbling
and maybe some lipstick is exchanged but
yours was uh I felt beautifully put
together thanks that's really nice for
you to say and yeah I worked hard on it